welcome to this video playing at the
five-minute blitz game against Joe Jenn
Joe Jenn from from Norway and he's
saying hi so let's say hi as well and
let's see yeah let's let's play a color
or change and rarely play that but it's
not a bad opening especially against d6f
black has already committed to e6 this
can be can be an interesting alternative
to two main line theory okay let's seem
so b3 here yeah probably
the other son has at least a very smooth
development yeah now I need to consider
if I like to allow him to take on
default or I can take on d5 myself I'll
take myself it's a bit of a matter of
taste what you what you prefer here okay
let's see maybe not sure let's try
Queenie to this threatens Bishop basics
he ignores it it's threatening this move
really it's a threat because the bishop
does not look great but now the light
squares are really really weak so on
this is why I considered it a threat
okay yeah he wants to play Knight c5
yeah all 94 yeah still okay I need to
study to do that okay but now queen
whale hmm yeah probably so to me too
it's not an ideal square for the Queen
this is Sir this must be admitted return
I don't it's this the only square
yeah yeah maybe a simple move like that
I mean it's a problem it provokes him to
take Mary Witten no this is a nonsense
of course it does not take this is so
one sided no no good player would take
on c3 ok so I'm I have some pressure on
the five though how to how to increase
it I can also now I can consider like b5
and this is actually quite an anointing
the threads night c7 Bishop f6
destroying the pawn structure and it's
not quite i'm not quite sure what he's
doing against it at least he doesn't
have an obvious reply rook c8 i can
probably just take yeah this is this is
11 look see one maybe just taking this
okay this is also an interesting move it
covers g-form and it intends 95 or 96
under favorable circumstances
it also introduces the idea to play f3
yet so it's very debatable if this is
ever good move but it it wasn't
available in the position before well I
actually I can consider it I can but it
doesn't look it doesn't look right okay
we'll have rope see one another EDM
you'll probably just mix the bishop quit
a 395 is also also interesting okay
let's play a little weddings I'm unsure
how to continue really Jeff I can take a
70 okay
yeah okay night back rook takes a to
fight if I take Kim let's let's prepare
this or threaten it let's aim and can
now I don't get to take the bishop this
is a problem now this was bad young
knight takes h3
yeah this is working it's not much that
I can do about it really check I have f3
available against nigeria forum it's a
it's obviously dangerous but what can
you do
mmm yeah I'm what 35 skanks this isn't
great oh yes rookie too that's that's
that's you can okay can only take one of
the pieces but still okay well those
those nights and do a nice job
protecting each other okay ch.5 this is
this you see missed well the position
isn't so clear I know k like should be
okay but it's not lost I don't think so
maybe on time
gasps almost the primals maybe a move
like g5 but this is also risky for black
time morning this is a very risky move
yeah I know why does certainly okay
check
it's just that the time is the the most
like most important thing you hear me
check now okay this is at least the draw
position wise this is winning of course
but the time yeah it's not an easy win
even because because of those pawns now
check possible to do and almost
impossible to do check check white
forfeits on time yeah I spent a
ridiculous amount of time for nothing
alright still those early games in this
session I especially bad in terms of
time management yeah well around here
why does an excellent shape but I really
didn't I didn't make anything out of it
because of those weaknesses black it's
just just bad him but then I didn't
didn't really play it well and then it
took me enormous time to play this
nonsense well this is probably ok but
here I should just add one point take
the take the bishop I shouldn't really
allow 2222 what what he managed in the
game that he can preserve this piece
this is not good my dear i'm in my metro
warning well the computer gives white a
straight win in this position okay this
is this means this attack is not working
yeah but still it it gets it gets very
tricky f3 seems to be better
hard hard move to play with limited time
but I understand him yeah and this is so
check check check yeah well this isn't
so clear i mean the compare likes likes
black button right here Black is not
better at all the way you plated Jack
White is just just a solid shape yeah he
just plays the losing move to to win on
time check and here it needs some
precision but white red really should
win I am probably with precise play can
get all the pawns but Dan's not not that
easy king wants to play king g3 the comp
yeah I don't know it's tricky i don't i
don't have many pawns mmm yeah hard to
tell if it's really a win for white yeah
the confirm it's very confident but I'm
not it's it's not not so easy I am I
need to get in fri black and easily get
this pawn and then I only have one porn
left maybe maybe it's the wind but I
lost this game on the clock basically
not on position okay so thanks for
watching